what percent of women are wife material  in 2022 40 how many bodies is too many  bodies for a wife to each his own I've  always said  I can be messy but not dirty  do whatever you're gonna do and just  check yourself and make sure you got no  STDs I think you're sugarcoating the  answer I think I because right now  those are some of the cleanest if we go  by textbook they're the cleanest by your  definition they're getting uh yeah  tested every week oh no absolutely but  that's why to each their own right so if  you say 20 then 20 is the top to where  they can be messy yeah well we're asking  you to to you all right what's your own  oh my quote  20 to 30 I guess I mean